.
* Ominöse Klänge *
Pornos auf Kinderhandys?
Ja, die gibt es. Keine Frage.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall
schon welche zugeschickt bekommen.
Ja.
Also ...
Ich fand es etwas eklig.
Ich war damals
ungefähr elf Jahre alt.
Ja.
Es ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl,
wenn man daran denkt,
dass man Menschen zuschaut.
Ich finde das nicht so ...
Keine Ahnung, ich weiss nicht.
Ich fand es nicht so cool.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich denke, zur Selbstbefriedigung
schauen das ... wohl eher Jungs.
Mhm.
Und ich denke, denen ...
gefällt es, oder so.
Meistens hiess es: "Schau,
ich habe hier ein Bild", oder so.
Dann schaute meist
gleich die ganze Klasse.
So war das.
Ja. So habe ich es in Erinnerung.
Dann haben wir halt
irgend so ein Video geschaut.
Eben, so ein ...
Wie sagt man dem?
Ein Porno.
Das ekelte mich, ganz ehrlich.
* Ominöse Klänge *
Diese Pornos
sind so einfach verfügbar.
Ich flüchtete mich in sie.
Das war sehr praktisch.
Elf, zwölf ist viel zu jung.
Da sollte man einfach sein Leben
geniessen, statt Pornos zu schauen.
Irgendwann sieht man es sowieso,
deshalb finde ich das Alter
nicht so wichtig.
Wenn man nichts davon versteht und
dann mit Inhalten bombardiert wird,
in denen SM zu sehen ist,
Leute geschlagen werden,
oder wirklich Heftiges
aus dem Darknet.
In diesem Alter
ist man noch nicht bereit.
Tatsächlich: Wenige Klicks,
schon ist man
mitten in Abertausenden Pornofilmen
aus allen möglichen Genres.
Am liebsten
würde ich schnell raus.
Harmlose Videos wie dieses
findet man wenige.
Konkret gibt es Filme,
in denen sexuelle Handlungen
mit Tieren vorkommen,
Filme mit sexuellen Handlungen
mit Kindern,
mit sexuellen Handlungen
mit Gewalttätigkeiten.
Da gibt's ganz vieles
in den abscheulichsten Variationen.
Wir möchten an einer Schule schauen,
was wirklich los ist,
kassieren aber nur Absagen: Das Thema
sei viel zu heikel, sagen alle.
Ausser das Schulhaus Steinhölzli
in Bern.
Lehrer Nils Lundsgaard will die Por-
nografie aus der Dunkelkammer holen.
Ein Teil seiner achten Klasse
traut sich vor die Kamera.
Geht ihr davon aus,
dass es in dieser Klasse
oder diesem Schulhaus
Leute hat, die das anschauen?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
- Ich denke schon, ja.
Weshalb wird das rumgeschickt?
Was ist cool daran?
Also ...
Ich weiss nicht, vielleicht
finden es die meisten spannend.
Aber ... ich weiss nicht,
wieso man das braucht.
Vielleicht,
weil er denkt, das sei cool,
das sei - blöd gesagt - jetzt in.
"Wenn ich das herumschicke, bin ich
beliebt in meinem Freundeskreis."
Vielleicht denken sie dann so.
Weil's grad was Neues ist,
und es ist auch ein wenig verboten.
Im Geheimen und so.
Ich glaube, das ist dann wie ...
Das finden die vielleicht cool.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass ich das sehen würde,
einen Tierporno oder so,
würde es mich wahrscheinlich
auch ein wenig verstören,
und sicher sehr ekeln.
Und wenn es noch Kinder sind,
die mit dem ganzen Thema
viel weniger Erfahrung haben -
das ist nicht gut.
Viele Kinder
sind digital bestens gerüstet.
Smartphone, Flatrate-Abo, viel Spei-
cherplatz - alles, was es braucht,
um Pornos zu behalten,
rumzuzeigen und weiterzuschicken.
Das ist strafbar.
Immer mehr Kinder werden deswegen
verzeigt - fast alles Jungs.
Im Kanton Zürich z.B.
gab es im letzten Jahr
278 Strafverfahren gegen Jugendliche
wegen Pornografie.
Das sind mehr als doppelt so viele
wie im Vorjahr.
Bei der Jugendanwaltschaft Zürich
darf ich
die Einvernahmeprotokolle anschauen.
Kopieren oder fotografieren
ist verboten, abtippen erlaubt.
Patrik Killer
ist leitender Jugendanwalt.
Er führt die Gespräche
mit den Jugendlichen,
die sich strafbar gemacht haben.
Wie treten diese Kinder auf,
wenn Sie hier bei Ihnen sitzen?
Ganz unterschiedlich.
Da gibt es die Möglichkeit von ...
... einer jungen Person,
die hierherkommt
und schon extrem beeindruckt ist
von der Polizei,
von der Einvernahme bei der Polizei.
Und vielleicht schon nächtelang
nicht mehr schlafen kann,
weil sie noch eine Vorladung der
Jugendanwaltschaft bekommen hat.
Bei anderen ist es wirklich so,
dass man einem jungen Burschen
auch mal sagen muss:
"So, du ziehst jetzt dein Cap aus,
du bist hier in einer Einvernahme."
"Das Handy wird auch ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt besprechen wir das."
Wo es dann darum geht,
dass man möglichst ...
... etwas rüberbringen möchte,
damit der Jugendliche checkt,
dass es Folgen hat.
Dass es nicht so eine Lappalie ist,
wie sie im Moment denken.
* Ominöse Klänge *
Die Strafen der Jugendanwaltschaft
gehen von einem Verweis -
das ist eine Art gelbe Karte -
über Bussen
bis zu Arbeitseinsätzen
oder der Anordnung
eines Mediennutzungskurses.
Bringt das etwas?
Wir erleben sehr oft,
dass Jugendliche,
die wegen Pornografie bei uns sind,
nur einmal hier sind.
Wiederholungstäter haben wir
in diesem Bereich nicht viele.
Und das zeigt ja, dass es wirkt.
Es ist ein Mosaiksteinchen,
mit dem man versucht,
einen Beitrag zu leisten.
Jugendliche sind lernfähig.
Die Dunkelziffer ist allerdings hoch,
da sind sich alle einig.
Schulhaus Steinhölzli, Bern.
Lehrer Nils Lundsgaard hat für uns
ehemalige Schüler/-innen
zusammengetrommelt.
Willst du?
Sie gehören zu den allerersten,
die mit Handy, WhatsApp und omni-
präsenten Pornos aufgewachsen sind.
Gewisse können Fantasien ausleben,
die sie im wahren Leben
nie machen würden.
Sie können auch Sachen schauen,
die sie gern ausprobieren möchten.
Natürlich ist nicht alles gut,
es kann auch zu heftig sein.
Dann kommen sie in Versuchung,
das selbst zu probieren.
Und dort ...
Es ist so, es gibt immer
gute und schlechte Seiten.
Ich sehe Pornos generell
eher als was Negatives.
Wenn man in einer Beziehung ist
und vielleicht mal neue Inputs will,
die man nicht kennt,
kann man gut mal auf etwas zugreifen
und schauen, was dort läuft.
Daran ist nichts Verwerfliches.
Aber grösstenteils hat es
sicher einen negativen Einfluss
auf die menschliche Psyche.
- Warum? - Weil's abstumpft.
Ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dass es einige Leute verändern kann,
wenn sie das tagtäglich schauen.
Sie haben dann ein ganz anderes Bild
von Menschen und von Frauen,
von Männern und Frauen zusammen.
Z.B. wenn sie dann ausgehen.
Dann beginnen sie,
Frauen anzufassen,
weil sie vielleicht denken,
die Frauen mögen das vielleicht.
Obwohl vielleicht das
komplette Gegenteil der Fall ist.
Darum - ja.
Hast du solche Dinge selbst erlebt?
- Ja, doch, schon auch, im Ausgang.
Um diese Jugendlichen muss sich
niemand Sorgen machen, scheint mir.
Und was sagen die Jüngeren
zur Pornoflut?
Was passiert,
wenn man das regelmässig schaut?
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
Also, ich glaube nicht,
dass das Realität ist.
Und dann hat man das Gefühl,
das würde so und so gehen.
Einen zu schauen, macht noch nichts,
aber dann
will man immer mehr schauen
und es selber machen,
das ist nicht gut.
Es ist unnötig.
Und ich glaube, es macht
mehr kaputt, als dass es hilft.
Was macht's kaputt?
Ich weiss nicht, einfach ...
- Das Gehirn.
* Rhythmische, tiefe Klänge *
Porno-Ästhetik gibt es überall.
Auch gängige Musikvideos
werden schnell sehr explizit.
Porno, verklärt als Lifestyle.
Sexualpädagogin Dominique Zimmermann
kennt die Lebenswelt von Erwachsenen
und Jugendlichen.
Sie macht Beratungen,
auch in Schulklassen.
Es prägt auf jeden Fall
das Sexualverhalten.
Ich habe auch schon oft
Junge gesehen,
die sich ungeheuer
unter Druck fühlen,
weil sie eben doch denken,
diese Bilder seien echt
und das Gefühl haben, sie müssten
auch so funktionieren können
wie die Schlaufe,
die sie da serviert bekommen.
Das kann bedeuten, dass Junge schon
Viagra schlucken wollen und ...
Das löst sehr viel Druck aus und
es entsteht dieser Leistungsgedanke,
was eigentlich aus meiner Sicht ..
... die Sexualität eher verdirbt
als aufwertet.
Mit ihren beiden Kindern
im Teenageralter
will Dominique Zimmermann
einen YouTube-Kanal aufziehen,
um eine Online-Sexualberatung
anzubieten.
Was sind Themen, die Junge ...
Sie weiss: Mit den eigenen Eltern
diskutiert kaum ein Kind
gern über Sex.
Und doch findet sie es wichtig,
Körperlichkeit,
Sinnlichkeit und Gefühle
auch anzusprechen.
In dieser Klasse gibt es einige,
deren Eltern
das nie thematisieren würden.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach
ein unangenehmes Thema.
Als ich mit meinen Eltern darüber
sprach, war es mir sehr unangenehm.
Dann haben wir in der Schule darüber
geredet, und wieder, und wieder,
und irgendwann ... Weiss nicht.
Geändert hat sich nichts,
es ist immer noch unangenehm.
Hi, Matty!
Das Verschämte aufbrechen -
Neuseeland versucht's
mit einem spassigen Präventionsspot.
... talk about the difference
between what you see online
and real-life relationships.
Ein Kampf gegen den Realitätsverlust.
Es kommt v.a. auch
auf den Konsum an.
Ob das dreimal täglich passiert
oder einmal im Monat oder - ja.
Ich würde sagen,
es sollte im Mass sein.
Hat man z.B. ein gutes Sozialleben,
konsumiert man weniger Pornos
als wenn man
den ganzen Tag zu Hause ist.
Und ob man in einer Beziehung ist
oder nicht, hat auch einen Einfluss.
Wenn man alleine ist
und nicht so dazu kommt
oder schüchtern ist und im Ausgang
nicht jede Zweite anmacht.
Dann wird man eher dazu verführt,
im Internet so was zu suchen
und in eine Abhängigkeit zu geraten.
Wenn man in einer Beziehung ist
oder ein offener Mensch,
hat man da keine Probleme.
Sich in den Tiefen des Internets
verlieren.
Wo niemand etwas fordert,
nur ganz viel angeboten wird.
Pornos können abhängig machen.
Im Teenageralter geriet Silvan,
so möchte er hier genannt werden,
in eine Pornosucht.
Pornos
dominierten viele Jahre sein Leben.
Es verändert einen auch.
Dessen muss man sich bewusst sein.
Man geht am echten Leben vorbei,
wenn man nur Pornos schaut.
Pornos stehen so einfach
zur Verfügung.
Ich flüchtete mich einfach da
hinein. Das war sehr praktisch.
Ich merkte gar nicht,
was ich verpassen könnte.
Es ging mir gut dabei.
Seit einigen Jahren macht Silvan
eine Therapie bei Franz Eidenbenz
in der Suchtfachstelle RADIX.
Es ist dann eine Pornosucht,
wenn die Kontrolle verloren geht.
Man meint vielleicht,
man könne es kontrollieren.
Aber das ist nicht mehr der Fall.
Sowohl in Bezug auf die Zeitdauer
als auch auf die Art,
es wird extremer.
Die Sucht ist auch dadurch defi-
niert, dass es weitergeführt wird,
trotz offensichtlicher negativer
Auswirkungen im realen Leben.
Die Leistung, z.B. Schule,
aber auch die Beziehungsfähigkeit -
Freunde, Kollegen usw.
Mit den Pornos an sich
hatte ich lange keine Mühe.
Wahnsinnig unangenehm
war die Situation,
in der die Kollegen
von ihrem Vorabend erzählten,
was sie unternommen haben
mit anderen - natürlich Frauen.
Und ich ...
... sass am Vorabend vor dem PC.
Und schaute mir einen Porno an,
sonst nichts.
Das kam regelmässig vor und ich ...
Ja, ich verpasste da etwas.
Ging es ums Verpassen oder darum,
ein krasser Aussenseiter zu sein?
V.a. das Zweite, der Aussenseiter.
Nichts sagen zu können,
die Situation nicht zu verstehen.
Und v.a. das Gefühl zu haben,
dass das fast unmöglich ist.
Sucht ist vielfach eine Flucht.
Sie kann ganz zufällig beginnen.
Aber meistens ist die Ursache
ein Problem in der Realität.
Man hat keinen Erfolg,
traut sich etwas nicht zu.
Oder man bekommt nicht
die nötige Unterstützung,
um dieses Hindernis zu überwinden.
Dann taucht man ab -
und fühlt sich dort plötzlich
besser als in der Realität.
Hatten Sie in der Realität
keine Beziehung, keine Freundin,
keine solchen Erfahrungen?
Nein. Als Teenager war ich oft
verliebt und probierte einiges aus.
Und als sich
mein Konsum steigerte ...
... nicht mehr.
- Warum nicht?
Ja ...
Es stand mir immer alles im Weg.
Ohne Erfahrungen war es schwieriger.
Und diese Pornos stehen
so einfach zur Verfügung.
Ich habe mich einfach
da hinein geflüchtet.
Das war sehr praktisch. Ich merkte
gar nicht, was ich verpassen könnte.
Es ging mir gut dabei.
An welchem Punkt stehen Sie jetzt
in dieser Verarbeitung?
Sind Sie nicht mehr pornosüchtig?
Jein. Ich finde,
man ist süchtig, wenn es stört.
Und mein Konsum
stört mich nach wie vor. Weil ...
Ich bin nicht clean,
wenn man so will.
Aber ich bin in Behandlung
und ich arbeite daran.
Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich,
dass das gut kommt mit mir.
Seit eh und je
sorgen sich die Erwachsenen,
dass Bilder nackter Haut und Sex
die Kinder verderben könnten.
(Originalton) Auch behütete Kinder
werden mit sexuellen Darstellungen
konfrontiert,
denn Abbildungen von erotischem
Inhalt begegnen uns überall
und in jeder nur erdenklichen Form.
Allerdings war es lange viel ein-
facher, die Bilderflut einzudämmen.
Z.B. am Zoll.
Das ist jetzt die "Jasmin".
(Originalton) Die Verantwortung,
die dieser junge Zollbeamte
der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber
zu tragen hat, ist gross.
Und heute?
Pornos durchdringen die Gesellschaft.
Und alle sind sich einig,
dass man Kinder vor zu heftigen
Bildern schützen muss.
Was kann man denn tun?
- Nichts.
Also doch ...
- Es ist schwierig zu kontrollieren.
Doch, man kann,
ich hatte auch eine Sperre.
Meine Mutter installierte eine App,
als sie dahinter kam.
Das war eine Sperre,
aber die betraf dann auch Inhalte,
die z.T. gar nichts
damit zu tun hatten.
Z.B. "Men's Health" - da wollte ich
was lesen, das gesperrt wurde.
Wenn die Eltern dann
eine Nachricht bekommen,
besteht schon weniger die Gefahr,
dass man das anschaut.
Aber sagen wir's so:
Wenn man will, findet man einen Weg.
Wenn der erste Kontakt zu Pornos
solch verstörende Videos
auf WhatsApp sind,
dann ist es schon gefährlich, aber
wenn man normal aufgeklärt wird ...
Gut, Aufklärung ...
Ich weiss, wie das ist,
man ist jung und interessiert.
Wenn meine Mutter mir etwas verbot,
tat ich es extra.
Am Ende kommt es auf die Person an.
Jeder muss in dieses Messer laufen,
um zu merken, wie es schneidet.
Deine Mutter kann dir 100-mal sagen,
du sollst es nicht tun,
wenn dir das nicht passt,
machst du es trotzdem.
Das ist so.
- Viel kann man also nicht tun.
Und was ist
mit den Anbietern und Providern?
Kann man sie nicht
in die Pflicht nehmen?
Das weiss bestimmt Guido Berger,
Leiter der SRF-Digitalredaktion.
Verschiedene Länder versuchten es,
bis jetzt scheiterten alle, sagt er.
Filter seien zu wenig präzise.
Wir sind dem Internet
also ausgeliefert?
Die kurze Antwort heisst:
Ja, natürlich.
Wir haben ganz viele Kanäle
geschaffen,
auf denen Inhalte
wahnsinnig chaotisch daherkommen.
Das ist einfach so
und das geht nicht mehr weg.
Die Situation heute ist völlig
anders als noch vor 20, 30 Jahren.
Damals war es viel kontrollierter,
über welche Kanäle
Inhalte zu einem Publikum kommen.
Dementsprechend schwieriger
ist es für alle Beteiligten,
diese Inhalte zu filtern
und zu entscheiden,
welche dieser Inhalte zum eigenen
Kind kommen sollen und welche nicht.
Was ist denn
mit der Nutzerregistrierung?
Wäre das auch eine Variante?
Ja, da bewegen wir uns irgendwann
einfach relativ nahe an China.
In China passiert das.
Wenn Jugendliche im Internet gamen
wollen, müssen sie zur Polizei.
Sie müssen sich registrieren.
Der Provider - es gibt landesweit
nur einen, der das kontrolliert -
hat dann das Alter bestätigt
und kann abhängig davon entscheiden,
ob sie z.B. 1 Std. oder am Wochen-
ende spielen dürfen oder nicht.
Das wäre alles möglich.
Aber da baut man einen
grossen Überwachungsapparat auf.
Ich bezweifle, dass man
in den westlichen Demokratien
den Willen hat,
so weit zu gehen für diesen Zweck.
Natürlich kann man schauen
und Filter installieren.
Aber ich denke, das ist ein Kampf
auf verlorenem Posten.
Wenn man das Gefühl hat, das sei
der Weg, das möglichst zu vermeiden.
Es ist viel wichtiger, davon
auszugehen, dass es passieren wird,
dass man über diese Bilder spricht,
dass sie nicht die Realität zeigen.
Und angenommen,
die Kinder haben Material gesehen,
kann man darüber sprechen,
was das mit ihnen gemacht hat.
Die Pornos sind da.
Ein Grossteil der erwachsenen Männer
konsumiert sie regelmässig.
Die Kinder ganz davor zu bewahren:
unmöglich.
Gehen Sie davon aus,
dass die kommende Generation
ein anderes Verhältnis zur Sexualität
haben wird als die ältere Generation?
Das hat ganz sicher einen Einfluss.
Sie werden eine andere Sexualität,
ein anderes Verhältnis dazu haben.
Wie wissen wir noch nicht genau,
das ist offen.
Es ist auch individuell verschieden.
Ob jemand merkt, eigentlich braucht
er mehr Romantik und Zärtlichkeit.
In Abhebung dieser Bilder.
Oder ob Menschen sich freier fühlen
und etwas davon ausprobieren wollen.
Die meisten Jugendlichen
können sehr gut damit umgehen.
Wenn jemand eine einigermassen
gute Balance hat, merkt er:
"Das ist spannend, aber mit der Zeit
habe ich genug, mache was anderes."
Das zur Beruhigung der Eltern.
Offen bleiben, heisst die Devise.
Die Kinder müssen irgendwie merken,
dass es kein Tabuthema ist.
Sicher darüber reden.
Eine gute Mischung finden zwischen:
"Es ist verboten", aber doch auch:
"Komm unbedingt,
wenn du so etwas erhältst."
Dann kann man es löschen
und eine Lösung finden.
Ja, darüber reden, es ansprechen.
Mein Ziel ist, dass sie keine Angst
haben, damit zu mir zu kommen.
Jeder kann machen, was er will.
Wenn sie das machen wollen,
dann ...
... ist das ihnen selbst überlassen.
Sie machen sich strafbar.
Sie sind quasi selbst schuld,
wenn sie dann erwischt werden
oder wenn es rauskommt.
Ich glaube, wenn das in der
Gesellschaft etwas lockerer wäre,
würden auch nicht mehr so viele
konsumieren.
Es wäre klar: Es ist, wie es ist,
man müsste es nicht mehr schauen.
Ich persönlich finde, man sollte
offen mit diesem Thema umgehen.
Warum?
- Weil es zum Leben gehört.
Die Pornowelt.
Ob man sie will oder nicht.
Die Jugendlichen
setzen sich damit auseinander.
Die Eltern sind oft alarmiert,
hilflos. Reden wäre das Rezept.